eu vim falar que hoje sobre um dos
assuntos
interessantes do mundo né que é o futuro
e quando a gente fala de futuro
inevitavelmente a gente se depara com
paradigmas quebra de paradigmas e mais
do que isso com o surgimento de macro
revoluções e só para vocês entenderem
entenderem dentro dessas máquinas
revoluções existem as microevoluções
estabelecidas aquelas como a internet
que chegaram ea gente não teve tempo de
se preparar
assim como a manufatura de tinga também
conhecida como impressão em 3d
a realidade virtual a robótica ea gente
vai falar aqui também um pouco sobre
essas máquinas revoluções emergentes e
pra essa sim a gente tem tempo de se
preparar e olhar com cuidado pro futuro
e elas são a inteligência artificial
os cyber sei prinz e o pós humanismo
está a primeira delas que eu quero falar
um pouquinho hoje é a manufatura aditiva
também conhecida como prototipagem
customizada e o que a gente sabe sobre a
manufatura de tiva hoje é que a
habilidade que a gente vai ter de
imprimir o que a gente quiser nas nossas
casas vai fazer
inevitavelmente com que as empresas
tenham que pensar em qual que é o papel
delas na vida dos consumidores
a gente está falando de 2012 já
impressões de pizza hambúrguer esses
cookies é e haja inclusive o ano passado
foi impresso uma semente que foi
plantada germinada e comida então a
gente vê um futuro fantástico traz
alimentos com é a impressão em 3d em
2014 foi impresso um carro inteiramente
em 3d durante um congresso de tecnologia
é feito pela louco motors inclusive e
não obstante em 2017 a gente vai ver uma
ponte que se auto imprimir é feita pela
mx3 de lá em amsterdã na holanda
são também casas a gente fala de
técnicas avançadas e revolucionários
como por exemplo o consultor rafting que
são impressas hoje aqui e já são
possíveis
impressas em lugares como a lua por
exemplo então são ambientes fantásticos
que a gente vai construir e vai dar base
inclusive para impressão de órgãos em
2025 como foi feito pelo anthony ayala é
um protótipo apenas mas a gente sabe que
daqui a quatro anos a gente vai
conseguir ter decido se totalmente
impressos vascularizados e funcionais
com bill impressoras e isso é
maravilhoso porque quando a gente fala
de futuro e quando a gente fala dessas
marcas revoluções o que é importante a
gente saber é que elas deixam valores e
esses valores sim a gente pode aplicar
no agora e o que é uma promoção da
manufatura de tiva deixa como valor é a
vida sob demanda é acessibilidade e
flexibilidade é conveniência é a
permissão de customização e
personalização de absolutamente todos os
aspectos da nossa vida e há também a
questão de desenhar marcas com corações
marcas que realmente se conectem com as
nossas emoções ea gente vai pra 2ª macro
revolução que é a realidade virtual à
realidade virtual palavra chave é
simulação e ela oferece uma mudança
totalmente diferente na nossa
perspectiva o que em algum momento a
gente via agora a gente vive
experiências dentro de um cenário
simulado
e foi com base nisso que a gente
desenvolveu uma plataforma de pesquisa
então a gente se muda diferentes
ambientes coloca pessoas para viver
esses diferentes ambientes ea gente
consegue medir o que essas pessoas dizem
com base é em uma percepção que elas têm
é a imaginação e também os dados
biológicos a mensuração de dados
biológicos e não é à toa que a realidade
virtual o principal valor que ela deixa
pra gente é justamente esse mecanismo de
empatia você se colocar no papel de
outra pessoa então a gente consegue
finalmente entender questões tão
importantes para a nossa sociedade como
por exemplo a discrimina discriminação
de gênero ou a condição é sobre os quais
vivem os refugiados
de de guerras como como foi muito bem
salientado a gente fala também da
quantificação de tudo tanto de aspectos
funcionais de ou como você olha por onde
você está andando como emocionais micro
expressões leitura corporal tudo isso de
uma forma quantificada
a gente vê também uma mudança muito
drástica de multi para o mini canais
tudo vira canal a gente sai de websites
né que são ambientes totalmente
estáticos para web em barmens ambientes
em 3d onde sem dúvida alguma o pagamento
é é uma característica muito importante
um dos valores mais importantes que a
gente tem que alavancar junto com essa
macro revolução nem vou falar um
pouquinho pra vocês também sobre
robótica a última é macro revolução
dentre as estabelecidas ea robótica a
palavra chave é a automação sem dúvida
alguma ea gente consegue observar um
padrão de vocês conseguem observar o
padrão é das imagens que ocorre então o
primeiro a gente tem pessoas com pessoas
aí a gente tem muitas pessoas com uma
máquina aí a gente tem uma pessoa com
muitas máquinas ea gente vê um futuro de
máquinas com máquinas e é claro nem
falam que a robótica vai substituir o
nosso trabalho e sem dúvida alguma vai
substituir muitos dos nossos trabalhos é
principalmente com o aperfeiçoam a
perfeição aumento de robôs
multipropósitos como é o caso do
backstage que conseguem aprender é com a
gente fazendo mas outra coisa que a
gente não fala quando fala de futuro é
justamente das oportunidades que a
robótica também traz pra gente é são
coisas é como por exemplo a capacidade
de aprender a programar de uma forma
simplificada por meio de linhas como o
robot faz hoje ou até mesmo o único e oe
loura que é um sensor que você coloca na
cabeça e ele consegue quase que ler o
seu pensamento e fazer com que o objeto
se se mexam com a força do seu
pensamento a gente vai ver surgir campos
o dia
a gente nunca ouviu falar antes e que
vão fazer com as nossas vidas fiquem
muito mais simples porque a gente vai
ver um crescimento de tecnologias
criativas em casa cada vez mais a gente
também é outro aspecto muito importante
a internet das coisas
a era da conectividade tudo está
conectado seu sapato está conectado com
o seu ar condicionado e ele é ativado
quando você tá chegando em casa em dias
quentes uma inteligência fantástica que
é permitido por meio dessa era de
conectividade e a questão de empoderar
pessoas com conhecimento é nossa
obrigação em poder há pessoas com
conhecimento pessoas que saibam qual e
tem um claro qual é o seu propósito
diante desse cenário de macro revoluções
bom e agora eu quero fazer essa pergunta
pra vocês né
o que acontece quando a gente tem robôs
digitais competindo por trabalhos
intelectuais
a boa notícia que o futuro vai ser
maravilhoso a gente vai ter cada vez
mais tempo para nos focar em coisas que
realmente importam e a primeira dessas
macro e volumes homens emergentes é a
inteligência artificial ea palavra chave
é a engenharia de conhecimento
e o fato é que a inteligência artificial
ela vai expandir as nossas mentes como a
electricidade fez com os nossos músculos
alguns anos atrás e é muito fantástico
quando a gente fala de inteligência
artificial porque um dos aspectos mais
filosóficos sobre a inteligência
artificial
a habilidade que a gente vai ter de
conhecer a nós mesmos são como clones
das nossas mentes que permitem com que a
gente saiba realmente quem nós somos
então a gente prevê é um futuro
fantástico ea gente pode criar esse
futuro cada vez mais fantásticos para
que a gente possa se focar em coisas que
realmente importam é a automatização
quase que da nossa mente também por meio
dessa engenharia
é de conhecimento e técnicas como
linguagem natural e odin turning que
tenham cada vez mais desenvolvidas e não
é à toa quando a gente fala de
inteligência artificial que a gente fala
de dados de informação dado é muito
importante para a inteligência
artificial é o alimento dos algoritmos
em dados em informação a gente não
consegue estabelecer essas conexões
então é muito importante a gente pensar
como a gente está capturando inclusive
esses dados
outro aspecto fundamental é que as
pessoas adiem que nós vamos nos
robotizar né
isso não é verdade é a máquina que vai
criar essa capacidade de se conectar
emocionalmente é quando a gente pensa em
fazer erros na importância de de cometer
erros algo que não erra
não é inteligente é importante que a
gente erre é importante é que a gente
aprenda cada vez mais com os nossos
erros indubitavelmente um dos setores
que mais têm a aprender com isso é a
educação é a capacidade de errar e
aprender a errar e aprender e crescer
dentro desse cenário que a gente
vislumbra indo pra tá quinta
macrorregulação tecnológica que é o
cyber sempre a questão do cyber sempre
em justamente essa simbiose tecnológica
é a gente vê cada vez mais gadgets
tecnológicos acoplados a nossa biologia
como por exemplo é o caso do google é
desenvolvido em parceria com a
farmacêutica que chama novartis que
consegue medir o nível de açúcar no
sangue por meio da lágrima e não é só
isso a gente já conhece patentes é de
lentes que conseguem por exemplo gravar
e tirar foto com um piscar isso o começo
quando a gente fala dessa dessa simbiose
e tecnológica e do cyber sempre a gente
vê uma explosão da biotecnologia e isso
faz com que a gente pense em implantes
não só visuais mas também cognitivo
implantes medulares a gente é começa a
estudar cada vez mais a importância de
próteses de edson esqueletos de tudo que
vai fazer com que não só a gente consiga
ter uma solução para deficiências mas
como uma forma da gente conseguir ser
cada vez mais capazes e claro assim como
todas as macrorregiões tem seus valores
cyber serpente a gente vai aprender
aí além dos cinco sentidos a gente vai
conseguir ouvir cores como por exemplo
uniu hardware sem porque não cheirar
texturas porque não desenvolver a
imaginação como sentido criatividade
como sentido existem forças pra gente
conseguir ampliar cada vez mais os
nossos sentidos e por meio disso tem uma
outra forma de interação e recepção com
o mundo e claro é se inspirar em
processos biológicos quando a gente se
inspira na biologia 1 poucas chances de
algo dá errado como é o caso é do futuro
um de plástico serão substituídos por
fungos ou até mesmo aquela garrafa que
enche sozinha de água que foi inspirado
em um besouro na namíbia que levantam as
asas e conseguem condensar vapor de água
e se hidratar e viver fantástico futuro
que nos apresenta o que a gente tem pela
frente ea última macro evolução é
justamente o pós humanismo a
palavra-chave do pós humanismo é a
transcendência é esse momento onde o que
é biológico que é natural que é
tecnológico o que é artificial ele se
fundem a gente não consegue ver e
perceber diferenças entre esses aspectos
da vida e do futuro porque a partir do
momento que a gente tem a tecnologia
crescendo num nível e exponencial ea
gente chega num ponto é que é
descrevendo pelo lakers ou como a
singularidade que é o momento onde uma
máquina vai
mais capacidade de processamento do que
todos os cérebros humanos juntos na face
da terra ea gente entra num aspecto da
nanotecnologia então em algum momento na
revolução anterior onde a gente tinha
que agir e tecnológicos agregados ao
nosso corpo esses nanobots agora passam
a tarde dentro da nossa corrente
sanguínea e conseguem curar doenças de
uma forma sem precedentes como a gente
nunca viu antes na vida ea gente caminha
para um futuro de abundância um futuro
onde todos teremos acessos acesso a
essas tecnologias e é claro é um momento
onde as máquinas elas se comunicam com
máquinas sem a interação humana é um
momento onde a corrida espacial faz com
que a gente finalmente de a importância
de a sustentabilidade como ela merece
esse momento onde a gente finalmente
entendi a tecnologia como natureza ea
gente consegue olhar para o ato de
cozinhar por exemplo entender isso como
uma tecnologia natural e mesmo vai
acontecer pra outras tecnologias que a
gente ainda tem um pouco de dificuldade
de aceitar nas nossas vidas
tudo o que é futurologia né não é
leitura de mão não é leitura de tarô é
uma ciência e isso é muito importante
que fique claro e não só uma ciência que
estuda macro revoluções senão como é que
o consumo ele está mudando com esse
crescimento exponencial da sociedade por
meio da correlação entre pessoas entre
negócios e à própria tecnologia além de
suas intersecções então isso é
futurologia e de frente também do que
talvez vocês imaginam a futurologia ela
não pedisse o futuro ela criar radares
de futuros potenciais possíveis e
prováveis para que a gente possa
escolher qual é o futuro que a gente
quer criar por qual caminho que a gente
quer seguir esse pensamento é linear é
que não é mais
embutido já em novas gerações a gente já
tem outros pensamentos levam a gente
para outra dimensão onde não existe mais
uma diferença entre passado presente e
futuro o que existe é o agora e é o
agora o momento que a gente tem para
criar as condições para estar vivo
saudável e sermos melhores nesse futuro
e eu queria fechar com uma frase que
sempre me impactou muito que é eu sempre
me perguntei por que alguém não fazia
nada sobre isso até eu descobri que eu
sou alguém e todos somos alguém e todos
podemos construir um futuro os melhores
para que a gente consiga viver com cada
vez mais ética e harmonia entre todos
pessoal muito obrigado